みなさんこんにちは
8ですねいきなりですけれども私は先ず一つある物語をお話ししたいと思います
皆さん
イソップ物語ってご存知でしょうか
例えばうさぎとかめですとか
狼少年の話なんかが有名なんですけれども
どれもごくごく短い教訓的なお話ばかりになっています
その中で今日は一つこちら
これはね正すと水差しっていう話です
あるところに喉がカラカラに乾いたカラスが一応ありました
そして喉が渇いていますので水がどこかにないかなーと思って探しましたら
近くに水が下の方にだけ入った水差しを見つけたんですね
この水ガラスなどが乾いているので飲みたいですよね
けれどもこの上のところから
ちょっと水まで全然ちょっと届かなかったんですねで千葉市が
そして水指は意外と重たくてですね
転がすこともが茂ることもできません
このカラスはどう言ってこの水をもんだと思いますか
イソップ物語での話はこうです
+はですねその周りに落ちてい小石を一つ一つつまんではポチャんぼちゃんと水差しの
中に落としていきまして
会がてだんだん水かさが上がっていってお水をやっと揉むことができましたというお話
です
この話の教訓は
体だけではなくて頭を使おうということらしいんですけれども
私ですねこのお話の中にもう一つとても大事な教訓があるんじゃないかなぁと思うん
です
それを今皆さんにやっていただきたいと思いますのでご協力お願いします
皆さんいいですか皆さんの左手をちょっとが外前に出していただけますか
そうしましたら皆さんのこの左手の手首から肘の間のちょうど真ん中あたり
このためにはですねむずむず物とかよく捕ってきます
仲良いですよ困りましたそうしましたらここをあなたの右手を使わずに書いてみて
ください
どうぞ
ありがとうございます一番多かったのがあゴッド2頭とかで帰っている方が多かった
ですかね
膝て帰っている方もいらっしゃいました
この中で何もためらわずにまず最初に隣にいる人にここか良いから書いてって
手を差し出せた方いらっしゃいますでしょうか
何人かいらっしゃるかなと思ったんですけれどもいませんでしたね
そうなんですよね最初のカラスの話も損です
c 誰か協力者を見つけることができたとしてその人に手伝ってもらうことができたと
したらどうでしょう
もしかしたらもっと簡単にもっと早くこの店尺の中の水を飲むことができた母も知れ
ませんそしてもしかしたらその協力してくれたり
ちょっと仲良くなっちゃって一緒に楽しく水を空けられたかもしれません
でもですね今体験していただいて分かって頂けたかと思うんですけれども私たちは
悩み事やはこまりんとそういったものに直面した時にまず最初に自分だけで解決しよう
とするんですよ
自分の殻の中だけに閉じこもってその中目黒黒ゴーグルと悩んでしまう
ね
人に頼むのが恥ずかしいからとか
あとはそうですね申し訳ないかとか
または一人のほうがずっと楽だからっていう方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんし
あ全然思いつかなかったよと言う方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
でももしその壁をパッと取り払ってい
その垣根を越えて二していくことができるとしたらどうでしょう
その先にはどんな未来が待っていると思いますか
その先にはどんな人生が開けていくと思いますか
私は
人と人がつながることで起きてクルー
アズラ鷲早矢恥ずかしさや申し訳ないっていうの気持ち
そういった気持ちを守り超えたずっと先にある
桁違いのハッピーの存在を知っています
だから私は人と人と人とモノや自然がつながるということをつなぐっていうことですね
それを仕事にしています
ではまた
ハッピーと桁違いのハッピ一体何が違うのでしょうか
そのことを一つ例を挙げてお話ししたいと思います
ヘイトですね私は仕事からいろんな方から困りごとですとか悩み事を相談されることが
多いです
そんな中でそれをこう仕事に変えていっているんですけれども
今一番最近今現在ですね
タイムリーに手掛けている授業がありますのでそのことはちょっと聞いていただきたい
なと思います
今地域で起こっている問題の1つとしてこんなことがあります
農家の高齢化問題
そしてそれに伴って起こる耕作放棄地の問題
そしてそれからですまたね鳥獣被害ですとか
環境美化が損なわれるといったような問題が出ています
でもどうでしょうこの問題ちょっと考え方を変えてみます
そうすると
に高齢者は専門知識を持つ先生です
そして
よっ
耕作放棄地は自由に使える土地です
ここでですね
もう一つ違うところか別の問題はここに持ってきてつなげます
今地域で他にちょっとこう寄せられている問題の1つとしまして
今お仕事についていない若者がですね
まあ病気ですとか何らかの理由であ仕事に就けてね若者が増えているということがあり
ます
でも彼らは
人でです
担い手になりますよね若者をたからだと
素晴らしい
そして人で担い手という面でいけますと農作業に向いている福祉事業所さんや福祉施設
の皆さん
カレーがもせっかくですから子供に連れて行きましょう
ちょっとイメージしてみてください
自由に使える披露多い土地が広がっていますそこに専門家の存在になります
そしてにないと思います
なんか最初は困りもとばかりだったのにだんだんワクワクしてくるような音風に献花し
てきましたよね
でも一つ食べませんね何でしょ
そうそこの土地で何を育てるかということです
だったらばこんな風に考えますかね
例えば何を植えたら売れるかなぁとか
あともしくはこの地域であまり育てられていないような珍しい分を調整してみようとか
そんなねアイディアを出される方もいるかもしれません
でも私はこんな風に考えるんです
半身ここでどこかで困っている人やを持っている団体さん
そして授業さんなどはいないかなーと思って探します
探して探してすごく探します
こういうのはこうやみくもに何でもつなげればいいという問題ではありませんので
一つの問題をより大きなハッピーにしていくためには年数をすごくかかることもあり
ますこの件についてもそうでした
1年2年探して探して色々な方に教えていただいたりしながら見つけました
生薬です今小役が息していて困っている人たちがいます
席ほど高齢化問題と言いましたけれども
高齢たが何もなんか損ばかりの問題ではありませんよね
日本も全国そうですし世界でもそうなんです
ただちょっと私高齢顔問題って言ってしまうのはちょっと違うかなと思うんですけれど
も
名前聞けばいいことですからねまあただ名前ってする人が増えるということはやっぱり
起こしを飲む人が増えますよね
ですので生薬を原材料として作られていきます感冒薬
この漢方薬の需要がどんどん伸びているんですね
ということはそれに伴って価格もどんどん高騰しています
そんな中
現在日本で使われている生薬
こちらは約80%から90%か
外国からの輸入品になっているんです
さあパッドバー虫籠の生薬を日本国内でもっと作ることができるとしたらどうだろう
そしたら漢方薬をお薬として必要としている患者さんたち
そういう人たちにとってもより安定した価格でより安定した品質で利用していただける
ようになるんじゃないかなと思ったわけです
あっと骨がですね
発泡よしと言うんですかみんなを幸せになるっていう顔が浮かんだんですね
そしたらこうどうはやいですすぐ行動しちゃうんですけど
日本国内にいくつか症薬メーカーさんというのはありますけれども
ちょっといろいろなご縁がありまして大阪にあります
栃本天海堂さんという生薬メーカーさんと契約を結びました
そしてこの春かな長野県内のいくつかの農家そして福祉事業者さんそして無情
の若者たちと一緒に生薬栽培を始めたところです
今ねあげた一つ一つの問題がそれぞれに幸せになる方法を探していくということも十分
できます
全然悪いことじゃないと思います
でもどうでしょう
こうして一つ一つの団体へ人が繋がっていくことで起こってくる
責任感ですとかやりがいねそういった心の豊かさなどが相乗豪華となって合わさった時
そこには大きな桁違いの happy が生まれると思いませんか
私はこの図を
桁違いのハッピーと呼んでいるんです
ちょっとひとつここで昨日までなかったんですけど言いたいことがあってこのてっとも
そうだと思いました
皆さんね聞いてくださる方そしてシャベル私たち
そして皆さん本当にスタッフの方そして思いついた伊藤さん
1人ではできなかったことが遡上が効果となって今ここに大きなハッピーがあります
四段になっちゃったんですけどこちら見てください
8ですねー
一番目の写真は生薬を栽培するしているところというかですね
植え方を専門家のことも教わっているところですね真ん中にいるのが先生です
栃本天海堂の先生です
そしてこちらもそうです終わっているのは投機という植物です
こちらは上田市にあります福祉事業所さんなんですけれども
こちらでほんのつい23日前ですね植え始めたところです
なのではがちょっとサダチみたいねますけれども今植えているところです
私がこうイメージしています伝えたいことと桁違いの happy をつくっていくと
み姉の仲良くなるよっていうのイメージ
伝わったでしょうか
ってですね私この状態を作り出すためにとても大事にしているポイントがあります
それはですね今私が話した中に入っていたんですけれども私は
困りごとや悩み事や弱み
それらを強みに変えてつながっていくということをしています
なぜならバー
困っていることほど隠された強みが存在すると思うからです
これもちょっと漠然としてますので一つだけねちょっと聞いてください
例えばお洋服ありますよねこの洋服
これが洗濯をした時に痛んだりから待って伸びたり自陣食べちゃったらやだなあという
思いがあるからこそいろんな種類の洗濯洗剤ができたりですとかあと洗濯ネットって
いうものが発明されたりしてみますよね
そのようにこの世の中は困りごとや悩み事そういったことをより良くしようとして
どんどん良い世の中人生が豊かになっているのではないでしょうか
私と同じように繋がことを仕事にしている人がいますのでちょっと短く2人だけ紹介さ
せてください
長野県内で年間数多くのフリーマーケットを開催しています
フリムネット信州の代表立石恵子さんという方があります
彼女はこう言っています
出会った人たちの良いところ素晴らしいところとくぎがなるべく多くの人の人目に
さらされることが大事だ
そう思ったので良しいつもイベントをしようと決めました
フリーマーケット開催している方の最初のその想い
そこですよすごいですね素晴らしいと思いました
そしてもうひと方
ことですね
教育問題などのことですね一生懸命カウンセリングをしています
心理カウンセラーの上も春へソンという方がいます
ウェーボさんはこんな風に言っています
どんな困難な教育問題であってもさまざまな専門家が手を取り合って一生懸命協力し
合って支援を始めようとした時
どんな問題でも必ずそれは解決に向かって動き出します
と言っています
米もさんは専門家同士をつなぐということでその先の happy を作り出している
んですね
このように人と人をつなぐということはいろいろな方々があると思います
もし
あなたにいつか
その先のハッピーというものがイメージすることができたとき自分にはどんな関わり方
ができるだろう
私に何ができるかなっていうふうにさん
あえて言ってもらいたいなと思います
それでは
最後になります
いいですかここは皆さん次第でこのスピーチが成功するかどうかにかかっているんです
が話が最初に戻ります
皆さん左手を前に出してみてください
したろ皆さんも左手の手首から肘の真ん中あたり
ちょうどこのあたりがムズムズ痒くなってきます
さっきより輝くて岩盤ができませんさあ皆さん
この痒いところを自分の右手を使わずに耐えてみてください
ありがとうございます
me
はいありがとうございます一番最初の時と比べてどうでしたでしょ
何か変化がありましたかどちらがより心が温かくなったでしょうか
かゆみを取るという問題解決一つの幸せ以上の何かを感じていただくことができました
でしょうか
みなさんが幸せでありますよ
ありがとうございました